being a victim is great by the way
people love it it's not great it is
great oh it's great that's why people
want to be victims CU it feels so good
because nothing's your responsibility
nothing's your fault I don't think I
understand the point you're making of
course I understand people love being
victims because there's something in it
there is something in it ultimately it's
counterproductive though it it does not
but it's the same with fenel it feels
great for a bit doesn't it yeah I
imagine you alleviate the pain that you
have deep inside by taking something
that gives you a short-term burst of
pleasure and that's what victimhood is
it gives you a sense that nothing's your
fault you are where you are because of
the circumstances of your life and in
the immediate moment that feels good but
it's not it's not making you good
overall